Nos piden resolver y graficar la solución
del sistema de ecuaciones que tenemos aquí
y lo primero que se me ocurre es que podemos
eliminar una de las variables,
si nos fijamos en la "x",
aquí tenemos "4x" y aquí tenemos "2x",
al sumar las ecuaciones tal cual están,
nos daría "6x" eso no las eliminaría,
pero si multiplicamos este "2x" por -2,
nos va a dar "-4x"
y al sumarlo con "4x" se van a cancelar las "x".
Hagamos eso, multipliquemos esta ecuación,
esta segunda ecuación por -2,
voy a multiplicar ambos lados
de esta ecuación por -2
y la razón de esto es que este "2x" se convierte en "-4x" para eliminarlo con el "4x" de arriba,
pero tengo que multiplicar por -2
todos los términos del lado izquierdo
y del lado derecho
para que no se altere la igualdad.
Así es que la segunda ecuación se transforma
en "-4x", -2 por "2x" = "-4x",
-2 por "-y" más "2y"
lo cual es igual a 2.5 por -2, -5.
Esto es simplemente la segunda ecuación
multiplicado por -2 y voy a escribir debajo
la primera ecuación,
que es "4x" menos "2y" igual a 5.
Y voy a sumar estas dos ecuaciones.
Y ahora ya podemos eliminar,
al sumar "-4x" con "4x" se van a cancelar,
sumemos entonces estas 2 ecuaciones,
vamos a sumar lado izquierdo con lado izquierdo
y lado derecho con lado derecho
y lo podemos hacer
porque estos dos son iguales,
estamos haciendo lo mismo
a ambos lados de la ecuación.
¿Y qué nos queda?
Si sumamos "-4x" con "4x" esto se cancela,
nos va a dar 0... 0, podemos poner inclusive "0x",
se fueron las "x", ahora si sumamos
"2y" y "-2y" también vamos a obtener 0, "0y"
y esto va a ser igual a -5 más 5,
también es 0,
¿qué está pasando?
Estamos obteniendo una ecuación que es 0 igual a 0, ¿qué sucede aquí?
Si bien esto es cierto, también es un poco
bizarro, teníamos "x" y "y" en la ecuación
y ahora todo, todo se ha cancelado,
vamos a explorar esto.
Vamos a graficar estas ecuaciones para ver
qué es lo que quiere decir esta ecuación
0 igual a 0 que hemos obtenido.
Déjame graficar esta ecuación de arriba,
la voy a hacer en azul...
se encuentra en forma estándar,
la voy a llevar a la forma pendiente ordenada...
voy a reescribir la ecuación aquí...
es "4x" menos "2y" es igual a 5,
podemos restar "4x" a ambos lados,
quiero despejar la "y",
entonces, ¿qué tenemos?
Estos términos se van,
nos queda "-2y" es igual a "-4x" más 5,
ahora vamos a dividir entre -2...
entre -2 ambos lados de la ecuación,
estos se cancelan, nos queda "y"
que es igual a -4 entre -2 esto es "2x",
este término es 2 menos 2.5...
menos 2.5.
Vamos a graficar esta ecuación.
La ordenada al origen es -2.5, -1, -2, -2.5,
ahí está la ordenada al origen
y la pendiente es 2,
si avanzamos 1 en la dirección positiva,
si avanzamos 1 a la derecha,
tenemos que subir 2, 1, 2...
si avanzamos otro a la derecha,
volvemos a subir 2 y ahí tenemos 3 puntos,
voy a trazar la recta lo mejor posible...
esta es la parte más difícil de este tipo
de problemas....
trazamos la recta... y ahí la tenemos...
esa es la ecuación de arriba.
Ahora, déjame graficar la ecuación de abajo...
y lo voy a hacer en este color verde.
La ecuación de abajo es,
"2x" menos "y" igual a 2.5, ahora,
vamos a restar "2x" a ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿qué nos queda?
Se cancelan estos términos en "x",
"-y" es igual a "2x" más "-2x" más bien más 2.5,
vamos a multiplicar o dividir entre -1,
nos queda "y" es igual a "2x" menos 2.5.
Vamos a graficar esta ecuación, ojo, quizás
ya te diste cuenta de algo interesante,
la ordenada al origen es -2.5...
-2.5 y la pendiente es 2, es decir,
tenemos exactamente la misma recta...
exactamente la misma recta.
Y eso lo obtuvimos algebraicamente, cuando pusimos las ecuaciones en su forma punto pendiente,
esta es la primera ecuación en forma punto pendiente, que coincide con ésta,
que es la segunda ecuación,
así que la identidad 0 igual a 0,
nos está diciendo que ambas ecuaciones
representan a la misma recta,
el sistema de hecho tiene
una infinidad de soluciones,
cualquier punto sobre esta recta que corresponde
a ambas ecuaciones, va a satisfacer el sistema,
si me das un valor de "y" arbitrario,
obtengo el valor de "x" en la ecuación de arriba
y esa pareja "x", "y",
va a cumplir con la ecuación de abajo.
Así es que el sistema tiene una infinidad de soluciones,
es una sola recta.